Це Данило Лєсніков. Йому 20 років.
А це - Софія Євстігнєєва, 19 років.
Відколи вони себе пам'ятають,  Росією керує
один і той же чоловік - Володимир Путін.
Обоє належать до так званого "покоління Путіна".
Утім, їхнє ставлення до російського президента кардинально протилежне.
Софія належить до прокремлівської молодіжної групи "Cєть".
Це стартовий майданчик для молодих митців, дизайнерів та журналістів.
Доти, доки вони - у фан-клубі Путіна.
Софія - журналістка.
Вона вже майже рік дописує на онлайн-сайти,
здобуваючи, так би мовити, професійний досвід.
Софія дуже тішиться, що Путін - учетверте президент.
Для мене Володимир Володимирович уособлює,
власне, всю державну структуру Росії.
Тому що, як я вже сказала, я його
бачу все своє життя.
І він іноді вчиняє дуже мудро, я вважаю.
Навіть найчастіше.
Данило Лєсніков дивиться на все геть інакше.
Як студент економіки він критикує стагнацію в Росії
і стурбований тим, що Путін обмежує демократичні свободи.
Ось уже чотири роки, як він в опозиції до влади
і спонукає своїх товаришів до протестів.
Він був ще немовлям, коли Путін прийшов до влади.
І переконаний: зміни давно назріли.
Якби замість Путіна була б якась людина,
яка не любить обманювати,
для якої засоби брехні, насилля недопустимі, було би набагато краще.
було би набагато краще.
Позиція Данила для представників покоління Путіна нетипова.
На останніх виборах понад 70% виборців до 24 років
голосували за Путіна. Однак Данило каже,
в колі його знайомих майже ніхто не є прихильником чинного президента.
У принципі, це питання критичного мислення.
Тому що, по суті, підтримувати Путіна об'єктивно нема за що.
Його можна підтримувати лише в результаті промивки мізків,
пропаганди російської.
Софія натомість вважає, що багатьом опозиціонерам
просто бракує відчуття реальності.
Мовляв, лише така людина, як Путін,
може впоратися з викликами, які нині стоять перед Росією.
Сильного, впевненого, з принциповою позицією.
Це дуже важливі речі. Хтозна, можливо,
Путін на ще один термін піде. Але я би хотіла, щоб
ця людина в жодному разі не була слабшою від Володимира Володимировича.
Мені дає надію насамперед моє покоління.
Скажімо, на мітингах, де ми буваємо,
дуже багато людей мого віку. Це все енергійні,
вільні люди, які вільно говорять те, що думають.
Я думаю, за нами майбутнє в будь-якому випадку.
Але до цього ще далеко.
Щонайменше 6 наступних років політичне майбутнє Росії
визначатиме незмінний Володимир Путін.